[Music]
cody simpson's sister ali simpson has
been hospitalized after suffering a
major neck injury on new year's eve the
23 year old australian model revealed
she actually broke her neck in a freak
accident sharing this update with her
fans on instagram along with the news
that she also tested positive for
kovid19
here's what happened simpson revealed
that she dove headfirst into a shallow
pool on new year's eve and hit her head
which resulted in multiple severe
fractures
quote i am extremely lucky to be alive
and or not quadriplegic as it just
missed my spinal cord ally went on to
explain that no immediate surgery was
necessary and that she will have to wear
a neck brace 24 7 for the next four
months as she recovers from the injury
i'm just sort of getting prepared for
that fans have been very supportive so
far sending the model well wishes and
ally sent all her love back writing on
her instagram stories quote i am so
overwhelmed by the response i've been
getting to my injury feeling very loved
and lucky i cannot thank every single
one of you enough for your kind and
thoughtful words it's a special feeling
it really is also giving his support is
ali's big bro cody in fact cody himself
is no stranger to swimming back in
december 2020 the singer revealed he
qualified for his first olympic trials
the all-day musician sends his sis a
sweet message on instagram stories
writing quote you're a miracle i love
you and i am so grateful you're safe
[Music]
you